nearly 25 years ago in the fall of 1981
the late Robert hours who taught here at
the college for many years wrote one of
the first major reviews to appear in
this country of Salman Salman Rushdie's
Midnight's Children in that review Bob
Towers described Midnight's Children as
one of the most important novels to come
out of the english-speaking world in
this generation and after receiving the
Booker Prize that same year Midnight's
Children would go on a decade later to
be awarded the Booker of Booker's given
to the best book to have won the prize
in its first quarter century in that
same review Bob towers observes that the
narrative momentum of a novel is oddly
enough not sustained by action but by
style a style that seems to me he writes
almost miraculous in its range and
adaptive capacities Salim's voice Slim
is the narrator of the novel
Salim's voice incorporates many voices
in its own right it is prolix vivacious
elusive and highly literate capable of
many shadings and of both subtle and
abrupt abrupt shiftings of tone and it's
true this is one of the great pleasures
of reading the work of Salman Rushdie
the almost infectious energy of its
syntax we the reader are enlivened by
the sheer vitality of the narrator's
voice and this vitality seems linked in
my mind to another great pleasure of
reading Salman's prose and that is the
transformative power of metaphor for in
a novel by Salman Rushdie a thing is not
simply like another thing a thing is
that other thing in Midnight's Children
a member of the British aristocracy
William meth Wald sells his large Bombay
estate rather than rather cheaply to
Salim's father and to several others but
on two conditions that the entire
contents be retained by the new owners
and that the actual transfer should not
take place until midnight on August 15
1947 which also happens to be the date
that Britain handed over sovereignty of
India to its own inhabitants and so
Salim and his family as well as several
other families
must each live in a house with the
previous owners possessions including
moth-eaten dresses they used brassieres
used combs dilapidated ceiling fans half
empty pots of food until the formal
title to that house is given to them on
August 15th and in this way the
strictures of the British transfer of
India to its own inhabitants comes alive
the metaphor is the reality or as
William meThe old himself puts it it
seems that beneath the stiff English
exterior looks a mind with a very Indian
lust for allegory and this lust for
allegory for metaphor is something we
find throughout Sal moans large body of
work in his new novel Shalimar the clown
we find Shalimar as a boy learning how
to walk a tightrope don't think of the
rope as a safety line through space his
father had said think of it as a line of
gathered air the Rope and the air are
the same when you know this you will be
ready to fly and so in this way Shalimar
father was initiating his son into a
mystery a rope could become air someone
writes a boy could become a bird
metamorphosis was the secret heart of
life
metamorphosis was the secret heart of
life didn't like that line as much as I
did I guess it also seems to be the
secret heart of Salman Rushdie's fiction
and I should point out that this
fascination with allegory with metaphor
with metamorphosis is often in the
service of a larger thematic concern in
the case of Shalimar the clown and this
larger thematic concern is the
devastating consequences of the
seemingly intractable conflict between
two competing forces of religious
nationalism Hindu and Muslim Indian
Pakistan and in the novel as it is in
life one of the Centers of this raging
conflict is the disputed territory of
Kashmir a couple of weeks ago in the
wake of the powerful earthquake that
killed so many thousands tens of
thousands in Kashmir I was listening to
an interview with a pakistani foreign
minister who was refusing to accept
helicopters being offered by india to
help in the rescue effort solely because
those
helicopters would be flown by Indian
pilots then in the next segment an
Indian official was interviewed and it
was clear that if the situation were
reversed if Pakistan were offering aid
in the former helicopters to India the
Indian government would not accept those
helicopters if they were flown by
Pakistani pilots even as hundreds of
thousands stand homeless and destitute
in Kashmir and when I heard this report
on the radio I thought immediately of
Salman Rushdie and shell mother clown I
also thought of something Salman himself
had said about that novel at the level
of the characters it is a story about a
betrayed love a broken love that can't
be fixed and in the same way he said I
think the culture of Kashmir has also
been broken in a way that almost
certainly can't be fixed and in the
novel the metaphor is clear the betrayed
love the broken love of Shalimar and
Buyi one of whom is Muslim one of whom
is Hindu this broken love is Kashmir and
Kashmir itself is perhaps a metaphor for
the larger brokenness the larger
affliction that devastating need for
certainty absolute certainty
fundamentalist certainty a certainty
which has torn the world apart the
Boston Globe has said Salman Rushdie
great grasp of the human tragic comedy
its dimensions its absurdities and
horrors has made him one of the most
intelligent fiction writers in English
language please welcome Salman Rushdie
thank you
thank you well I was gonna read that bit
about the tightrope have to read another
bit anyway I'm gonna read for a little
bit and then and then we'll talk
Leonard Lopez and I will talk and then
we might talk a bit so Charlie Meyer the
clown is a novel that begins in LA it
begins with the story of a father a
daughter and elderly quite distinguished
father max who used to be an American
ambassador in India and his illegitimate
daughter who's called India and it
begins but I tell you a little bit about
them and then he gets murdered on her
doorstep by the man whose calls himself
Shalimar who's got a job as his driver
but actually has been hunting him down
for years because many years earlier
Max who unfortunately is a bit of a
sexually predatory Indian ambassador
American ambassador quite unlike any
American ambassadors we know or or
presidents anyway he's had an affair
with her and this is this is a kind of
revenge killing so I'm gonna read you a
couple of bits and start with the with
the bit with a bit some of the early
stuff from Los Angeles she's about 24
India and she wants to grow up to be it
or she's just beginning to be a
documentary filmmaker and he's elderlies
must must be sort of pushing 80 by this
point anyway her name was India she did
not like this name people were never
called Australia were they or Uganda or
English ata or Peru in the mid-60s
her father Max Ophuls Maximiliano Falls
raised in Strasbourg France in an
earlier age of the world had been
America's best-loved
and then most scandalous ambassador to
India but so what children were not
saddled with names like Herzegovina or
turkey or Burundi
just because their parents had visited
those lands and possibly misbehaved in
them she had been conceived in the east
conceived out of wedlock and born in the
midst of the firestorm of outrage
the twisted had ruined her father's
marriage and ended his diplomatic career
but if that was sufficient excuse if it
was okay to hang people's birthplaces
around their necks like albatrosses then
the world would be full of men and women
called euphrates or Pisgah or his tachi
wattle or Woolloomooloo
in america damn it this form of naming
was not unknown which spoiled her
arguments lightly and annoyed her more
than some what Nevada Smith Indiana
Jones
Tennessee Williams Tennessee Ernie Ford
she directed mental curses at a raised
middle finger at the wall India still
felt wrong to her it felt exotic
colonial suggesting the appropriation of
a reality that was not hers to own and
she insisted to herself that it didn't
fit her anyway she didn't feel like in
India even if her color was Richard high
and her long hair lustrous and black she
didn't want to be vast or
sub-continental or excessive or vulgar
or explosive or crowded or ancient or
noisy or mystical or in any way
third-world quite the reverse she
presented herself as disciplined groomed
nuanced inward irreligious understated
calm she spoke with an English accent in
her behavior she was not heated but cool
this was the persona she wanted that she
had constructed with great determination
it was the only version of her that
anyone in America apart from her father
had ever seen these days she had herself
firmly in hand on her 24th birthday the
ambassador came to her door she looked
down from her fourth floor balcony when
he buzzed and saw him waiting in the
heat of the day wearing his absurd silk
suit like a French sugar daddy holding
flowers yet people will think you're my
lover India shouted down to max my
cradle snatching Valentine
she loved the Ambassador when he was
embarrassed the pained furrow of his
brow the right shoulder hunching up
against his ear the
and raised as if to ward off a blow she
saw him fracture into rainbow colors
through the prism of her love she
watched him recede into the past as he
stood below her on the sidewalk each
successive moment of him passing before
her eyes and being lost forever
surviving only in outer space in the
form of escaping light rays at the rim
of the known universe an unimaginable
creature would someday put its eye to a
telescope and see max approaching
wearing a silk suit and carrying
birthday roses forever borne forward on
tidal waves of light moment by moment he
was leaving her becoming an ambassador
to such unthinkably distant elsewheres
she closed her eyes and opened them
again no he was not billions of miles
away amid the wheeling galaxies he was
here present incorrect on the street
where she lived a woman in running
clothes rounded the corner from Oakwood
and counted towards him appraising him
making the easy judgments of the times
judgments about sex and money he was one
of the architects of the post-war world
of its international structures it's
agreed economic and diplomatic
conventions his tennis game too was
strong even now at his advanced age the
inside out forehand his surprise weapon
that wiry frame in long white trousers
carrying not much more than 5% body fat
could still cover the court he reminded
people of the old champion Jean Bharata
those few old-timers who remembered
Bharata he stared with undisguised
European pleasure at the joggers
American breasts in their sports bra as
she passed him he offered her a single
rose from the enormous birthday bouquet
she took the flower and then appalled by
his charm by the erotic proximity of his
snappy crackle of power and by herself
accelerated anxiously away 15-love
from the balconies of the apartment
building the old Central and East
European ladies were also staring at max
admiring Li with the open lust of
toothless age his arrival was the high
point of their month they were out on
mass today usually they gathered
together in small street corner clumps
or sat in twos and threes by the
courtyard swimming pool chewing the fat
sporting inadvisable beachwear without
shame
usually they slept a lot and when not
sleeping complained they had buried the
husband's with whom they had spent 40 or
even 50 years of unregarded life stooped
leaning expressionless the old women
lamented the mysterious destinies that
had stranded them here halfway across
the world from their points of origin
they spoke in strange tongues that might
have been georgian croatian was back
their husbands had failed them by dying
they were pillars that had fallen they
had asked to be relied upon and had
brought their wives away from everything
that was familiar into this shadowless
Lotus land full of the obscenely young
this California whose body was its
temple and whose ignorance was its bliss
and then proved themselves unreliable by
Keeling over on the Golf Course or face
down in a bowl of noodle soup
thus revealing to their widows at this
late stage in their lives the
untrustworthiness of existence in
general and of husbands in particular in
the evenings they sang childhood songs
from the Baltic from the Balkans from
the vast Mongolian plains the
neighborhood's old men was single to
some inhabiting sagging sacks of bodies
over which gravity had exerted far too
much power
others grizzle chopped and letting
themselves go in dirty singlet sand
pants with unbuttoned fliers while a
third giorgia contingent dressed sharply
affecting Berets and bowties these
naughty gents periodically tried to
engage the widows in conversation their
efforts with yellow glints of false
teeth and melancholy sightings of slick
down vestiges of hair beneath the doffed
Berets were invariably and
contemptuously ignored to these elderly
bows max was an affront the ladies
interest in him humiliation they would
have killed him if they could if they
had not been too busy staving off their
own deaths India saw it all the
exhibitionist desirous old women
pirouetting and flirting on the verandas
the lurking spiteful old men the antique
Russian super Olga semionovna a bulbous
denim clad samovar of a woman was
greeting the Ambassador as if he were a
visiting head of state if they had been
a red carpet on the premises she would
have rolled it out for him
she keeps you waiting mr. ambassador
what you gonna do the young I say
nothing against just a daughter these
days is more difficult I was a daughter
myself who for me my father was like a
god to keep him waiting
unthinkable alas daughters today are
hard to raise and then they leave you
flat i sir am formerly mother but now
they are dead to be my girls I Spit on
their forgotten names this is how it is
all of which was spoken while turning a
rooty potato in her hand she was known
to one and all in this her final
neighborhood as Olga Volga and was by
her own account the last surviving
descendant of the legendary potato which
is of Astrakhan a fully fledged
honest-to-goodness enchantress able by
the subtle use of potato sorcery to
induce love prosperity or boils in those
distant places and long gone times she
had been the object of men's admiration
and fear now thanks to the love of a
sailor since deceased she was marooned
in West Hollywood wearing outsize denim
overalls and on her head a scarlet
kerchief to cover her thinning white hat
in her hip pocket a spanner and a
screwdriver with the spilitt with a
Phillips head back then she could curse
your cat help you conceive or curdle
your milk now she changed light bulbs
and peered into faulty ovens and
collected the monthly rents as to myself
sir she insisted on informing the
ambassador I live today neither in this
world nor the last neither in America
nor Astrakhan also I would add neither
in this world nor the next a woman like
me she lives someplace in between
between yesterday and tomorrow in the
country of lost happiness and peace the
place of mislaid calm this is our fate
once I felt everything was ok this I now
don't feel I too am a national of that
country madam he interrupted her gravely
I too have lived long enough to acquire
citizenship there she had been born a
few miles east of the Volga River Delta
within sight of the Caspian Sea then in
her telling of it came the history of
the 20th century shaped by potato magic
of course hard times she said to the old
ladies on their balconies to the old
gentlemen by the pool to India wherever
and whenever she could corner her right
now - ambassador max on his daughter's
24th birthday of course poverty also
oppression dislocation armies servitude
today's kids they got it easy
they don't nothing I can see you are a
man of sophistication who has gotten
around some so of course dislocations
survival the necessity to be cunning
like a rat am i right of course
somewhere a man a dream of elsewhere of
marriage children they don't stay there
lives of their own they take them from
you and go war a husband lost don't ask
me about grief so of course more
dislocation hunger deception luck
another man a good man a man at the sea
then a journey across water the lure of
the West a journey across land a second
widowhood a man will not last present
company not included a man is not built
to endure in my life men were like shoes
I had two of them and they both wore out
after that I learned you could say to go
barefoot I see all guys actually quite a
minor character in the book
but she's in danger of taking the book
over so I will now stop down anyway max
is is not a very good father he's rather
quite often absent he shows up every so
often as today takes his daughter out to
lunch gives us some money and disappears
for long periods of time and even in her
childhood he was intermittent and when
he was there he would tell her bedtime
stories they weren't exactly bedtime
stories they were in fact extremely
weird as you will see I just will read
you one of the bedtime stories he tells
her when she's young his bedtime stories
told on those unpredictable occasions
when he had been at her childhood
bedside were not stories exactly they
were homilies such as Sun Tzu the
philosopher of war might have delivered
to his offspring
palace of power is a labyrinth of
interconnecting rooms max once said to
his sleepy child she imagined it into
being walked towards it half dreaming
half awake its windowless max said and
there is no visible door your first task
is to find out how to get in when you've
solved that riddle when you come as a
supplicant into the first anteroom of
power you will find in it a man with the
head of a jackal who will try to chase
you out again if you stay he will try to
gobble you up
if you can trick your way past him you
will enter a second room guarded this
time by a man with the head of a rabid
dog
and in the in the room after that you'll
face a man with the head of a Hungry
Bear and so on in the last room but one
there is a man with the head of a fox
this man will not try to keep you away
from the last room in which the man of
true power sits rather he will try to
convince you that you are already in
that room and that he himself is that
man if you succeed in seeing through the
Fox man's tricks and if you get past him
you will find yourself in the room of
power the room of power is unimpressive
and in it the man of power faces you
across an empty desk he looks small
insignificant fearful for now that you
have penetrated his defenses he must
give you your heart's desire that's the
rule but on the way out the Fox man the
bear man the dog man and the jackhole
man are no longer there instead the
rooms are full of half-human flying
monsters winged men with the heads of
birds eagle men and vulture men man
gannets and Hawkman they swooped down
and rip it's your treasure each of them
claws back a little piece of it how much
of it will you manage to bring out of
the house of power you beat at them you
shield the treasure with your body they
rake at your back with gleaming
blue-white claws and when you've made it
in our outside again squinting paint
painfully in the bright light and
clutching your poor torn remnant you
must persuade the skeptical crowd the
envious impotent crowd that you have
returned with everything you wanted if
you don't you'll be marked as a failure
forever such is the nature of power he
told her as
he slipped towards sleep and these are
the questions it asks the man who
chooses to enter its halls does well to
escape with his life the answer to the
question of power by the way he added as
an afterthought is this do not enter
that labyrinth as a supplicant come with
meat and a sword
give the first Guardian the meat he
craves because he is always hungry and
cut off his head while he eats puff then
offer the severed head to the Guardian
in the next room and when he begins to
devour it behead him too and so on when
the man of power agrees to grant your
demands however you must not cut off his
head be sure you don't the decapitation
of rulers is an extreme measure and
hardly ever required never recommended
it sets a bad precedent
make sure instead that you ask not only
for what you want but for a sack of meat
as well with the fresh meat supply you
can lure the bird men to their doom off
with their heads
snick snack chop-chop until you're free
freedom is not a Tea Party India freedom
is a war well in spite of all this we
had shorties and so on they actually get
on very well they're very close but
unfortunately quite soon after that his
24th birthday he gets killed and I just
thought I'd read you the gruesome bit
this is I say he's Shalimar the clown
who is the traveling player whose wife
ran away with the American ambassador
and Max was max has now got himself a
job as his driver and is and has evil
intentions like any other professional
in the field max knew that there was no
such thing as complete security the
videotape of the shooting of President
Reagan was the illustrative tool that
best demonstrated this here was the
president moving from building to car
these were the positions of the members
of the security detail all of the
positions were ideal here came the
assailant these were the reaction times
of the officers in the team the times
were extraordinary the officers response
is exceeding what was expected of them
the president was not shot because of a
mistake
there had been no mistake but the
president had been shot
POTUS was down the most powerful man in
the world surrounded by the planet's
security elite was not secure between
the door of the secure building and the
door of the armored car security was
percentages nothing was ever 100% and
nothing on earth could protect you
against the inside job the loyal traitor
the protector turned assassin ambassador
Max Ophuls allowed Shalimar the driver
to open the car door for him cross the
sidewalk and dialed his daughter's code
upstairs in her apartment the entry
phone rang India picked it up and heard
a voice she had only heard once before
in her life on the tape recorder she had
once left running by her bedside to
capture her sleep talk night language
when she heard that gurgling incoherent
choking noise she recognized it as the
voice of death and began to run
everything around her became very slow
while she ran the motion of the trees
outside the windows the noises of people
and birds even her own movements seemed
to be in slow motion as she hurled her
body down the sluggish stairs when she
arrived at the glass double doors to the
outside world she saw what she knew she
would see the huge splash of blood
across the glass the thick drag of blood
down towards the ground and the body of
her father
ambassador maximilian Ophuls war hero
and holder of the Latian or donor lying
motionless and soaked in a darkening
crimson lake his throat had been slashed
so violently that the weapon one of his
own Sabatier kitchen knives which had
been dropped beside the corpse had all
but severed his head she didn't open the
door her father wasn't there just a mess
that needed cleaning up
where was Olga somebody needed to inform
the janitor there was work for a janitor
to do moving steadily her back straight
and her head held high india called and
entered the elevator in the elevator she
stood with her hands clasped in front of
her like a child reciting a poem when
she was back in her apartment she shot
and locked the front door in the little
vestibule beneath a round mirror there
was a wooden shaker chair and she sat
down on it her hands
still clasped and resting now on her lap
she wanted the noise to stop the
shouting the braying sirens this was a
quiet neighborhood she closed her eyes
the telephone was ringing which didn't
matter there was a knocking then a loud
and knocking at her door which didn't
matter either a kitchen knife belonged
in a kitchen had no business on a
sidewalk an investigation was called for
this was not a matter for her she was
just a daughter she was just the
illegitimate but only child it was
important to go on sitting down if she
could keep sitting here for a year or
two it would be all right
sometimes the joy takes a long time to
come around again it was not her place
to save her father it was her place to
sit perfectly still until the joy came
around
Alouette gentille alouette Alouette
jetta Plumeri
she sat straddling her father's
shoulders facing him and they sang a la
ku a la ku Ella tete-a-tete alouette
Alouette oh and she somersaulted
backwards away from him
somersaulted away her hands in his hands
her hands in his hands her hands forever
and never more in his so begins with the
bird leaves he then goes back and tells
you why
so not her who done it but then why
there was crime and punishment
he said modestly so I thought I would
just go back to the other end of the
story and read you a little bit about
the beginning of the love story whose
betrayal leads to that crime of passion
which is to read you a little bit about
the moment when Charlie Morrow the clown
was a clown and what's more a clown in
love and has fallen is only at this
stage 14 15 years old and falling in
love with a girl from the village who is
a dancing girl in the same troupe of of
traveling players to which he belongs
into which in fact many people in the
village belong this is an old Kashmiri
folk tradition now almost extinct little
groups of traveling player
performing folk theater going around and
handing down the skills from generation
to generation anyway and just to
complicate matters he comes from a
Muslim family and she comes from a Hindu
family but that doesn't seem to stop
them there was the earth and there were
the planets the earth was not a planet
the planets were the grabbers they were
called this because they could seize
hold of the earth and bend its destiny
to their will the earth was never of
their kind the earth was the subject the
earth was the grabby there were nine
grabbers in the cosmos Surya the Sun
soma the moon booted Mercury Mangal the
Mars chakra the Venus prehospital
Jupiter Shani the Saturn and Rahu and
Ketu the two shadow planets the shadow
planets actually existed without
actually existing they were heavenly
bodies without bodies they were out
there but they lacked physical form they
were also the dragon planets two halves
of a single bisected dragon Rahu was the
Dragons head and k2 was the Dragons tail
that dragon too was a creature that
actually existed without actually
existing it was because our thinking
made it be until he found out about the
shadow planets Shalimar the cloud had
never understood how to think about love
how to give names to its effects of
moral illumination and tidal fluctuation
and gravitational pull the moment he
heard about the cloven dragon many
things became clear
love and hate were shadow planets to
noncorporeal but out there pulling at
his heart and soul he was 14 years old
and had fallen in love for the first
time in the village of patchy gum where
the traveling players lived it was his
time of glory his apprenticeship was
over and he had taken his professional
name he wanted to set the child aside
and be his new adult self he wanted to
make his father proud
of Shalimar the clown his son his great
father Abdullah the village headman who
held them all in the palm of his hand
it was the pundit pol I'll call who
taught him about grabbing and it was
upon debts green-eyed daughter Bhumi who
he loved her name meant the earth so
that made him a grabber Shalamar the
clown's supposed but cosmological
allegory didn't account for everything
it didn't explain for example her
interest in grabbing him back
except on performance days when they
were audiences within earshot she never
called him Shalimar preferring the name
he had been born with even though she
disliked her own name my name is mud she
said it's mud and dirt and stone and I
don't want it and she asked him to call
her bunny instead which was the local
word for the celestial Kashmiri channel
tree he would go out into the pine
forests above him behind the village and
whisper her name to the monkeys Moony he
murmured also to the who posed in the
high flower-strewn meadow of quel Marg
where he first kissed her boon Yi the
birds and monkeys homely replied
honouring his love
they sat by the river
Mosca Doon with the with the pundit
while he prattled about the cosmos
because he was a man who liked to talk
and it was a way for them to be together
speaking to each other in the silent
careful language of forbidden desire
while they listened to her father
babbling away as fluently as the
garrulous river behind his back Shalimar
the clown's fingers stretched towards
boonies and hers yearned for his they
were several yards apart sitting on
smooth boulders by the riverside bathed
in the relentless clarity of mountain
sunlight beneath the unbroken sky that
shone above them blew his joy in spite
of the distance their yearning fingers
were invisibly entwined Shalimar could
feel her hand curling around his digging
its long nails into his palm and when he
stole a look at her he could tell by the
light in her eyes that she could feel
his hand to warming hers rubbing it her
fingertips because the extremities of
her body were always cold her toes and
fingers and earlobes and the points of
the new breasts and the tip of her Greek
nose these places required the attention
of his warming hand she was the earth
and the earth was the subject and he had
grabbed it and sought to bend its
destiny to his will
well anyway during the course of this
day they agree that they're going to
meet that night in the mail in the
flower meadow above the village and do
all sorts of things to each other which
clearly fourteen-year-old people
never do except in books and if they do
they should not you just say no but in
this case they do so this is just to
finish with the you've had the gruesome
bit so this is the dirty bit when
Charlie Maura the clown found Boone ye
call waiting for him in the kale Marg
meadow a debate was raging in his mind
standing before him oiled of skin and
with wildflowers sensing the carefully
braided hair that hung around his
shoulders was the girl he loved waiting
for him to make her a woman and in doing
so make himself a man desire rose in him
but so did a counterforce he had not
expected restraint the shadow dragons
were battling over him rahu the
exaggerator and Ketu the blocker
fighting for mastery of his heart he
looked into boon Yi's eyes and saw the
tell-tale dry Venus there warning him
that she had smoked hashish to give her
the courage to be deflowered in the
subtly suggestive movements of her lips
to he could discern the cryptic
seductiveness cryptic seductiveness of
her condition
boonie boonie he mourned now you've
burdened me with the responsibility and
I don't know how to discharge it so lets
you know caress each other in five
places and kiss in seven ways and make
out in nine positions but let's not get
carried away
in reply Boone he pulled her shirt off
over a head and stood before him naked
except for the little part of fire
hanging low below her belly heating
further what was already hot don't treat
me like a child she said in a throaty
voice that proved she had been unsparing
in her drug abuse you think I went to
all this trouble just for a kiddy style
session of lick and suck when he heard
the unexpected course Ness of her speech
Shalimar the clown surmised that she
must have been very afraid indeed of
what she had agreed to do which was why
she had needed to derange herself so
completely okay it's not gonna happen he
said and the conflict within him grew so
great the two halves of the Dragon
end up his inside so completely that he
was physically sick
boonie laughed hysterically at the site
you think that's gonna put me off she
gasped between the sobs of laughter and
pulled him down on top of her mister
you'll have to try a lot harder than
that to get yourself out of this never
afterwards did boonie call utter a word
of regret or recrimination for what she
did in the meadow of Cal mug even though
the events of that night set her on the
road that led to an early death she
never reproached herself or Shalamar the
clown for their choice which was really
hers Shalimar the clown had been wrong
about that too she had not smoked the
hashish to abdicate responsibility but
to be sure of seizing her opportunity
nor was she afraid of what she had
chosen to do the dragon's head had won
her over long ago the spirit killing
tale had no power over her god she said
when it was over and that's what you
didn't want to do don't leave me
he said rolling over onto his back and
panting for joy don't you leave me now
or I'll never forgive you and I'll have
my revenge I'll kill you and if you have
children by another man I'll kill the
children also what a romantic you are
she replied carelessly you say the
sweetest things thank you
you write in this novel everywhere was
now a part of everywhere else Russia
America London Kashmir our lives our
stories flowed into one another's were
no longer our own individual discrete
the world was no longer calm and that
led John Updike to suggest rusty and his
Manhattan retreat is no longer a
third-world writer but a bard of the
grim one world we all in a state of some
dread inhabit so did you ever think of
yourself as a third world writer no I
thought there was rather odd locution of
mr. Updike's but there we are he's
entitled to his suburban opinion the
Shalimar the clown begins and ends in
Los Angeles are you suggesting that it's
a ruined American paradise just as
Kashmir is a ruined Asian well there's a
there's a there's a balance of paradises
being lost for in different ways I
suppose and in between them there's a
third one which is in Europe which is
Alsace which is where max originally
comes from on the franco-german border
in a way our sauce is the Kashmir of
Europe another place which has been
fought over where frontiers have snaked
back and forth and where I mean most
tragically of course in the Nazi period
many people lost their lives but in the
case of Alsace it's been resolved and we
we all can go there when we visit France
and wonderful wines and everything I
don't get that feeling about Kashmir no
Chris Peters the other way around it
used to be like that and now it's not
you know and I mean that certainly until
in fact relatively recently it used to
be like that I think if you had gone to
Kashmir even as recently as the early
1980s although it was beginning to be
discontented because the Indian military
presence was very oppressive the feeling
of the old culture of Kashmir is very
harmonious multiple culture in which
people of different faiths lived
perfectly happily together that feeling
was still there but now it's now it's
not smashed it's still there
it's Kashmir has been a perennial stage
for conflict since the Hindu Maharaja of
this predominantly Muslim population
chose to join Pakistan in 1947 all my
life I've been reading about how it has
been a place of great conflict you know
he did he did something even more
cowardly without he just ran away in a
Maharaja like way he just sprinted for
the door but he first he said it's what
he Indian you don't India but the Indian
army came in actually at that time oddly
with the support of many Kashmiri
politicians to defend it against the
Pakistani attack and as a result of that
first war which was way back in 1947 the
partition of Kashmir the de facto
partition of Kashmir into place and now
you have this so-called line of control
running through the middle that
ceasefire line and Pakistan runs the top
one for the northern one-third of the
valley in an India still controls the
bottom two-thirds and yes there be two
more wars fought about it was very
nearly a nuclear exchange about it two
or three years ago and now it is at
least the Pakistani side has in the
suffered this devastating earthquake Joe
talked about how there was limited
cooperation but there are the news today
brings hopes of more cooperation now
these two countries realize they have to
do something do you see any hope in that
well I mean I you know people keep
wondering whether this is going to solve
the problem between India and Pakistan I
don't think it is because their their
mutual suspicions are so huge but right
now I mean the humanitarian catastrophe
is just gigantic I mean you've got more
than two million people homeless of
probably a hundred thousand people
already dead and and and the Winterset
again and the winter in in the Himalayas
is no joke you know I mean it's it's
it's as brutal as a winter can be and a
lot of these people are simply in in
tents and there is no way you can
survive a Kashmiri winter in a tent I
mean so it's the fear is that it may
well be that more people will die in the
aftermath of the earthquake that were
killed in the earthquake it actually
could be a greater catastrophe
in terms of loss of life then the
tsunami was but the world is seems to be
suffering a little bit of compassion
fatigue you know that after the tsunami
and the Hurricanes and so on there's
really not enough aid getting there and
it needs to get there very fast but this
is an area that james hylton based his
book Lost Horizon on shangri-la
shangri-la causes all of the those
terrible winters yeah shangri-la
but of course shangri-la is a place
where human beings can be immortal and
safe from the you know from dangers of
real life as long as they stay inside
the valley Kashmir the real Kashmir is
not like that you know and and I mean it
used to be I can see why he got the idea
because first of all it is a place of
dazzling physical beauty I mean just
spectacular physical beauties high
mountain valley very very lush Safran
fields lakes little rushing rivers trees
and and and and very rich in produce
fruit fruit trees fruit orchards honey
bees you know and around this tiny
little valley these gigantic mountains
the biggest mountains in the world
and who said that it is quite
spectacular to look at and and then the
other characteristic which I think he
used for that kind of ideal life of
people living in shangri-la is that it
really was a part of the world where
people had worked out how to get along
yeah
which seems to be harder and harder for
us to do these days and you describe
childhood experiences where you saw that
sort of thing would you live in Kashmir
if the political conflict was resolved
no but I'd go a lot I mean you know what
used to happen I mean I never lived
there because I grew up in Bombay my
family had left my family was originally
Kashmiri but left in my grandparents
time but it was a plateau Kashmir is
incredibly cold in the winter you don't
want to live that there's in in the
summer it had always been a place to
which people from India would retreat
from the heat of the rest of the country
so we would go for a couple of months as
children in the
and so it became for me you know the
enchanted place of childhood but I also
went on going as a grown up you know so
I've been going there in fact the way
this story came about is that I was
there in 87 which was just about a year
and a quarter before the explosion of of
the so called insurgency and there was a
lot of tension around you said so-called
insurgents well I mean you can what do
you call it you know you could call it
an insurgency you could call it a
terrorist action and it depends which
side you could call it a Pakistani
inspired rebellion yeah you could call
it any of those things but you know that
the the moment of violence really began
in early 1989 and I was there about a
year before when it was very tense but
still calm and I actually was there to
make a documentary for British
television and I met a group of
travelling players not unlike the ones
in the book and I went to their village
and talked to them and they told me all
kinds of things about their lives and
the problem was we could not get them to
tell the truth on camera you know every
time we turned the camera on they would
say everything was fine you'd turn it
off and they'd tell you all kinds of
horror stories you know then you know
action and they would said they'd say
well tell us tell us about how you feel
about the Indian Army they would say oh
we are very happy with the idea Harvey
we loved the Indian Army you say no you
don't say yes we do sense said so in the
end in the end I had to tell the
producer that we couldn't use the
sequence because we didn't have the
story you know because it wasn't good
enough for me to say it you know it had
to come out of their mouths and it
wasn't coming out of their mouths so so
we cut the sequence out and I always
regretted it because I'd really loved
meeting them you know and had been very
touched by them and they just stuck in
my head and it's taken me all this time
whatever it is 17 years primarily the
first circus you ever saw the first
circus I ever saw was in Bombay they
used to be rather second-rate circuses
it would come quite often and we would
go this is not so much circus this is it
is more theatre circus although there
are some circus skills involved like
try walking him so on this is more of a
folk theater which performs old
traditional plays about the history of
Kashmir and and then some more modern
stuff derived from Bollywood movies and
so on but it was an art form which was
already endangered before the violence
began because you know in frankly in the
age of movies and television there's a
diminishing audience for village based
folk theater you know and so they
weren't getting a lot of work and one of
the things that was poignant about going
to their village was that you could see
they were highly skilled many of them
you know they were really very good at
what they did and yet they had very
little work so there was that sense of a
dying art but also it had touched me one
of your epigraphs is a poem by agasshi
dali he grew up in Kashmir and then
moved to the United States and it begins
I am being rode through paradise on a
river of hell did was he referring to
Kush yeah specifically in that phone
yeah he was I mean paradise and Kashmir
are phrases that are very odd terms that
are very very often linked I mean and
you and as I say when you get there you
could see why the probably first it was
probably first said during the 17th
century when the the Mughal Emperor
Jahangir who really loved Kashmir
actually built many of these big formal
gardens on the hillsides of which the
Shalimar garden is the most famous he
actually apt the Shalimar garden there's
an inscription of a verse which is
believed to be written by him which says
which translates as if there is a
paradise on earth it is this it is this
it is this so so if people have always
had that sense of it as being earthly
paradise you know and I think as in the
world we kind of have a need for the
idea of paradise you know and and if we
if we don't believe that we're going to
find it in a later life that we have to
go looking for it here and this was as
this was as close to it as I'd ever seen
where you've said this isn't so much a
story of Paradise Lost as a paradise
smashed up yeah because he what broke it
what destroyed Kashmir was not it was
not the Kashmiri people
you know it wasn't done by them to
themselves it was done by outsiders
Indians and Pakistanis to them and it's
not you know the myth of the myth of
Paradise Lost the idea of is the idea of
the fall the idea of human beings being
somehow unworthy for Eden you know and
being cast out of it but one assumes
that the Garden of Eden remains there
intact and in this case it's that you
know it's as if Adam and Eve were to
show up with submachine guns and hand
grenades and and smash the place up you
know and say it's about the it's about
the physical destruction of paradise and
that's at least this to your other
epigraph Mercutio's famous line from
Romeo and Juliet a plague on both your
houses so India and Pakistan are the
Montagues and the Capulets well this is
also a Romeo and Juliet story well
there's that thing it's at various
levels but yes when I first thought
about using that as an epigraph I was
thinking about India and Pakistan as
being the to more or less equal and
opposite villains of the piece you know
the Kashmiris themselves have when
whenever they've been asked I'd rather
consistently had the same point of view
which is would you both please go away
no and of course that's the point of
view that nobody pays any attention to
at all but Kashmir for the Kashmir ease
you're some kind of autonomous solution
is the one which Canaries have
consistently asked for for now 60 years
and that's the version that's that's not
on the table for discussion even so yes
a plague on both your houses seemed
appropriate
after that love scene where boondi says
what a romantic you are you say the
sweetest things obviously she doesn't
have much insight into her future
husband's marriage no she says she
thinks he wouldn't hurt a fly
yes she they're allowed to marry in a
mixed Hindu Muslim ceremony ash Alamos
father Abdullah the leader of these
traveling players says we are all
brothers and sisters here there is no
Hindu Muslim issue and of course the
rest of the novel's is just about how
wrong Abdullah is yeah so but it was a
thing a forgivable thing I mean you
could such a thing could have happened
you know I mean in do Muslim marriages
are not common in
even to this day and actually even in
Kashmir they're not common were not corn
and certainly when they when the two of
them when their love affair is
discovered they don't think it's going
to be cool I mean they think they're
going to be and they think they're in
big trouble and and it is really
surprising to them that the village
decides to take their side and to say
that you know these are our children and
they're good kids and they love each
other and why not you know that would be
that would be an unusual decision
truthfully but you know in a novel I
think the exceptional is often more
interesting than the normal so do you
think Shalimar wouldn't have hurt a fly
because after Bernie leaves him for Max
Ophuls
he becomes violent a professional killer
and the question is is simply because
his heart has been broken by the
betrayal of his wife or does he also get
caught up in the politics of the air
yeah it's not only I mean it would be
too too easy to say that somebody's
heart is broken and he becomes you know
terrorists in a kind of revenge that
would not work as as an explanation but
I think it's a it's a bunch of things
it's some of the some of the things
which push him down that road are
external which have to do with the his
sense of oppression you know in in the
valley by by the army the honor of his
manhood yes but first of all see the
thing is the Indian Army and something
that Indian people to this day really
tried not to look at the Indian Army in
Kashmir for 60 years has behaved
spectacularly badly which has been very
very cruel it has been it has tortured
people it has used rape as an instrument
of subjugation it has been atrocious by
any definition and that this should be
the behavior of an army of a democracy
is of course terrible until one thinks
about other armies other democracies you
you've written about his honor rapes in
both India and Pakistan which is another
matter of honoring manhood is another
example I assume of a plague on both
your houses but why do you think this
is is this something that is true to
both Islam and and yeah this is this
question of honor cultures you know it's
it's it's I think very difficult for
people living in the west where where
the if you like the moral polarity is
not between honor and shame you know I
mean if you know in in the
judeo-christian world the moral poles
are probably guilt and redemption you
know but but in in in places like South
Asia that is not so there's no sense of
an original sin is not a concept you
know
in Hinduism or Islam but honor and shame
are the absolute center of the moral
universe and so when people feel
dishonored in some way you know they
feel a man like him some simple village
guy would quite often feel that as a
real physical attack on his virility we
feel like a kind of emasculation
and his one of the things that makes him
pick up a gun is the desire to
reconstruct in his mind an idea of
himself as a man you know there's
there's a there's a there's a speech in
the novel he meets his mother on a on a
road between the two villages that are
in the novel and he he bursts out of
this into this great speech about how
she's lucky she's not a man you know
because a man has to suffer this and a
man has to respond in this way and a man
must stand up for himself so and he
can't take things lying down and you
know if you're a man you have to be a
man and you know that can be very
difficult and etc and in many ways I
think that's the key speech of the book
you know that's that's the the speech
where you see that he is talking himself
into becoming somebody very very
different than the young young fellow
he's being or you have a number of
people who become different from the way
we first meet them you you read about
Olga she's a a comic figure but another
one of the comic figures maybe a little
darker is the Indian colonel and even
perhaps the iron mullah you know they in
the case of the Indian Army colonel he
fantasizes about being
nicknamed hammer hammer by name hammer
by nature he imagined saying but instead
he has to settle for tortoise tortoise
by name
damned hardshell by Nature and later
becomes the leader of a savage
counterinsurgency campaign yeah I mean
really I guess those two characters the
character of the the opposed forces of
the Indian Army Colonel later a general
and the so-called iron man the firebrand
Islamic preacher who is believed to be
made out of scrap metal and therefore
can't swim because he would drown but
the ultimate zealot ultimate so the
opposite of anything that Western
civilization might recognize yeah but I
must say they're two of my real favorite
characters of the book it's one of these
you know the terrible thing about being
a writer is that it's sometimes your
villains are sometimes more lovable to
you that then the good guys you know I
mean Iago is a better part than a fellow
of course well actors like like yeah he
says why would you go to that why would
you play the good guy so and also
there's a little homage I suppose to in
the way in which particularly the Indian
Army colonel Colonel Quechua speaks
there's a little homage to Joseph Heller
in there you know I mean Joseph Heller's
amazing catch-22 language you know where
the sentence is the end of the sentence
contradicts the beginning of the
sentence you know I he's he is caught up
in if you like it a kind of catch dredge
new world where he believes himself to
be virtuous he believes himself to be
there for virtuous reasons of national
integrity and yet everything he is doing
is absolutely immoral and vile but has
to be justified in terms of the
virtuousness of his of his job and this
of course is a moral tangle that you
can't get out of and for which Joseph
Heller style comedy is very well suited
but he said it is it yeah well you've
been playing with that for a while now
going back at least as far as the ground
beneath her feet you have shifted back
and forth between high and low art
intellectualism and vulgarity often in
the same sentence
I'm in favor of vulgarity you know I I
like it I mean I think the novel is in
really the best sense of the word the
novel is a vulgar form you know the
novel is not an elite form it's if the
novel is the vulgar means what it means
of the people you know and recently
written in the vulgar languages the
languages of the local people not yeah
in in the hive not Latin they were
written in French the Latin word vulgus
means the people you know it means the
crowd and vulgar is it's actually about
how real people really live you know
it's not about it's not an elite it's
not a neat ivory tower kind of exercise
so if you if you look at the greatest
novelists you know Dickens or Fielding
or factory or you know etc they're
writing about real life but plunging
their hands as deeply as they can into
it you know you can't do that if all you
want to do is to write about elegant
stuff you know I mean I'm really in
favor of vulgarity but this but this has
changed this business of putting
everything together Midnight's Children
the language was more as I understand it
an attempt to to translate Indian speech
into English yes but here you're doing
something quite different perhaps it's
because you once said that you're trying
to suggest that homer and homer simpson
are the same kind of thing yeah I think
why not you know I like I perfectly
capable of of of enjoying the Iliad and
an episode of The Simpsons so I don't
see why one should know but the language
project you're right has changed because
I think you know you're right but I
wrote Midnight's Children one of the
things that interested me then was to
find a way to give some of the rhythms
of Indian speech to the English language
and as a certain point in which you feel
you've you've done that you know and
you've done it enough and what you you
don't want to do is to end up doing it
like a trick you know because you know
how to do it so you could do it like a
party piece you know the point at which
you you know what you don't want be
accused of trying to write some I
understand novels you know the point at
which you've done it enough you think
well what do i what else
and in this book because as you say it's
it's it's located all over the place you
know California to Kashmir to Strasbourg
etc each chunk of the book has a
different setting in time and space and
I thought that really each passage
should have its own language and rhythm
and flows and say the way in which you
write about events in contemporary LA
should not be the way you write about
events in a Kashmiri village 50 years
ago you know the and again the way you
write about events in nazi-occupied
Strasburg in in the 40s
you know they it seems to me that each
of those moments in place and time
required their own language you know so
so the book really in those five acts
you it's it's kind of a five act play
you know I think each section well at
least I tried to give it its own
language rhythms and manner which was
appropriate to the world it was this
does not appeal to every critic or the
review of Shalimar the clown and the
Weekly Standard admittedly a very major
major that made it absolutely impossible
is Salman Rushdie ranks somewhere
between James Joyce and Madonna in terms
of the contributions he's made to modern
civilization
I thought impera Dean you I thought I
might put that on the dust jacket
actually looked a the truth one of the
things that happens when you get to my
point in a literary career is that there
are you discover that there are people
who are not going to like what you do
whatever it is that you have done you
know I mean I could write you know war
and peace and they wouldn't like it you
know so so there's a point and I I kind
of know who they are you know and I'm
there so there are places where I know
that there is a kind of probably an
attack to be expected but on the whole
actually in Martin Amos that I have this
phrase for them out of a book being
published which is that you either get
away with it or you don't get away with
it
and I think my view in this particular
case I think I got away with it and I
think I think you know an enormous
number of the reviews were very positive
and very you know it kind of got the
point of what I was doing and then yes
there's
the odd one like that you know which but
they're responding to the way you have
changed they want you to write the book
of Booker's every time well the problem
is that that's it is the difficulty of
having done something which people have
responded to that if you do it again
they say oh yeah but it was very well he
did it before and if you don't do it
again they say well why isn't he doing
what he did before you know so that's a
that's a no-win situation let's talk
about some of the names Max Ophuls there
was a great filmmaker who worked in
Germany France and even Hollywood
why have you appropriated yeah I know I
you know I'm beginning to wish I hadn't
done it truthfully because because what
were you thinking and then as if there's
anything wrong with it it was like I'm
sure there were two Max Ophuls may have
been three all the time well I'll tell
you what I was thinking well you know
you could call character Alfred
Hitchcock could you I mean you you
wouldn't have to it wouldn't have to be
a fat guy you know with a voice like
that to scary stories to tell but it's
no really what the truth is I thought I
would change the name I really didn't
think the name would stay when I was
working out the character and I wanted
it to be a a franco-german you know name
which could be a Jewish family and so on
I remember writing down in my notebook
like Max Ophuls you know and then
assuming that it wouldn't be Max Ophuls
because he was a film director and then
the name just got stuck to the character
I mean I did make attempts to change it
and and every time I changed it I didn't
like or he didn't like you know yeah the
name and then I went through an enormous
process of self justification which I
can offer you some long if you like
later when when audience but for example
Max Ophuls the film director one of his
great movies is a movie called NOLA
Montes which is a film about the
betrayal of love and this is novel about
the betrayal of love and that's one
reason and another thing is that the max
wolf in her case it was lists in the
hell yes exactly
in her case was list well you know list
isn't always around it another thing is
that Max Ophuls the film director wasn't
really called Max Ophuls either
that was a stage name I mean he was
really called max Oppenheimer and then I
thought well if he stole the name I
could steal it back and and actually the
clincher for me was remembering that
when I had been young working in
advertising I had met big man who was a
PR guy for a mattress company and his
name was William Shakespeare lousy
father and mother mrs. Shakespeare
thinking what shall we call a little boy
I know let's call it William maybe
you're right
he didn't call himself was interesting I
thought about William Shakespeare the
mattress guy he wasn't called bill
Shakespeare he didn't call himself Billy
Shakespeare you know he said William
Shakespeare you know as if to say you
know that's my name and who cares that
some other guy had it first
but you love you love playing with names
Chalmers given name is no man which can
cut a number of ways but most of us
remember Odysseus's trick the Cyclops
and I've thought about what you've done
over the years you had fun with names in
fury there's a mention of a woman found
murdered in an alley named Carol Hattie
and I I i know you love popular culture
and i thought bob dylan's the lonesome
death of Hattie Carroll yes yes and that
was it right and then of all of those
plays on the words this guy in that
novel in this one we talked about India
not liking being called India well her
other name is Kashmiri yes Kashmiri
which is a which is the name of her
mother gave her before she was taken
away from her mother or the marina and
which she finds and I think actually in
this novel there's this kind of running
gag about people not liking their names
but behind the running gag there is the
fact that India is somebody from whom
the truth about her life has been very
largely concealed she doesn't know what
happened to her mother and when during
the and in a way you could say that the
story of the novel is the process by
which she finds out the truth about her
life and and the crucial moment is when
later in the book when she finds out
what who
was and and what her mother called her
you know and then she takes her real
name what she believes to be a real name
the name her actual birth mother gave
her and and it kind of closes a circle
you know so there's a moment there where
that naming but that gag about not
liking your name becomes a serious thing
well but talking about closing circles
since we're on the subject of names a
major character Midnight's Children is
named Padma oh yeah and so is your wife
yeah
yeah I don't she called coincidence well
it's even weirder because the other
major female character in Midnight's
Children is called Parvati Parvati the
witch which is my wife's middle name and
and you know I mean it's very bizarre
because it that you know my wife's much
younger than me at the time that I wrote
Midnight's Children there's no way that
I could have possibly I mean the only
thing is that they're not that uncommon
names I mean in India
Padma Parvati are both quite well you
know they're very common names I mean
they're like you know elizabeth-jane
you know so so it's not that surprising
a number of reviewers have suggested
that you wrote this novel in response to
what happened on 9/11 but I read
somewhere that you began it before you
even wrote fury yeah I did and what
happened you just couldn't figure it out
I couldn't figure it out ya know cuz as
I say I I'd had the idea way back in 87
you know and then I had this I had this
image of the murder store the murder
with which the which I read which would
the book begins with that was the first
thing I had really and initially I
thought maybe it was a political murder
you know it's an American ambassador
being murdered by a Kashmiri
counterterrorism yeah like a
counterterrorism guy being killed by a
professional assassin and you know it's
I I thought oh it's a it's a political
novel you know thriller set in LA and I
thought maybe it would be not a
particularly long normal you know it
would be this sort of taught at a James
Ellroy novel you know set in LA about
this murder and I I guess I'm not James
Ellroy you know I could I don't think
you know that many dirty words oh you'd
be surprised
although Shalimar is the title character
the book is really driven in a way by
the women Bruni and India and Shalimar
doesn't even get his own section until
halfway through the no yeah but he gets
the longest section to be fair no it's a
it's a story that accumulates it tells
you no I felt very what I was making the
book once I the points were I was just
gonna make is at the moment at which the
book came to life which was because I
set it aside and wrote fury and then
when I went back to look at it I thought
I came up with the character of boonie
and I realized oh that's the idea you
know that she's the wife of Shalimar and
the mistress of Max and the mother the
illegitimate child and and it's about
her in a way you know she's the the
hinge of the book and at that point I
thought oh well I'm not telling a
political story I'm telling a story
about a revenge tragedy you know a crime
of passion and at that point the book
began to move and yeah I mean I think
that I I just had these four people the
two men in the two women and I felt very
unusually and usually very insecure when
I'm writing the book you know I mean I'm
not sure if it's working and I'm scared
about whether I can kind of wrestle it
to the floor you know and once I had
these four characters I felt for me very
unusually secure I felt that I had these
four people I really trusted them you
know as characters I knew who they were
I thought if I do right by them you know
they they'll do right by me and so I
would just would pay attention to their
needs
I would describe to people the process
of writing this book as a kind of
listening that I would pay to spend my
day listening to the needs of these
characters and let the story unfold as
they desired and there's none of you and
this there's assassin says the man he
was going to kill was a godless man a
writer against God who spoke French and
had sold his soul to the West
yeah what's not me obviously oh okay
good yeah I think you've always denied
biographical inclusion we talked about
fury and we have Malik Salonika
his mid-fifties he's from bombay's left
his wife and child behind in England to
come to New York he becomes a celebrated
figure in America gets involved with a
beautiful Indian woman also living in
New York I know why you would think that
was won't to biographical well because
he's a doll maker yeah he's a doll maker
no but you see he's also somebody if you
look at the actual engine of the
character he's somebody who was sexually
abused as a child which has left him
with with terrible scars he's somebody
who becomes capable of of acts of
violence which scare him so he almost
murders his sleeping wife and small
infant child again with a knife again
with a knife and and he in America
becomes prone to curious blackouts and
coincidentally there appears to be a
serial as a series of serial murders
taking place in Manhattan and he wonders
if it's him and then every journalist
would ask me if it was an
autobiographical I would say well not
exactly you know no I mean but I learnt
actually from one of the lessons I
learned from fury that so many people
assumed that because yes he is a point
of view character you know and he's
deliberately placed close to me because
what I wanted to write about was the
business of arrival you know that I
didn't want to write a novel about New
York of the kind that somebody born and
raised in New York would write no
because that's not for me to do we loved
it much more than you seem to know I
mean you know why am I here if I don't
like it what I did is in the character
of Miletus Wonka I put all the grumpy
stuff I mean he's very grouchy and all
the kind of the planets grouchiness
about America I put into his mouth and I
and I surrounded him with you know
something which to use the back Tinian
term was carnivalesque you know i so
surrounded him with something which I
thought was much richer and more
enjoyable and you know I'm the author of
the whole book not just the grouchy
[ __ ] and and I thought that that's what
the book does it takes this fight
picture of of New York and puts in the
middle of it this very skeptical
disenchanted grumpy voice but basically
what we're saying is that people tend to
read into things that things that aren't
always there yeah but I've learnt
therefore try and avoid having me
characters in books you know and one of
the things I really like about this book
is there is not a me character in it
there's nobody you can say that's the
person speaking for the writer you know
and I think it may be something peculiar
to me that just because of what happened
in my life so much of my life has been
out there in the newspapers you know
that people know too much about me well
they know too much about what the
newspapers tell you and even the murder
in the in the in this novel takes place
after Max Ophuls has been on the Jay
Leno Show yeah I've been on the Jay Leno
Show I hope I was on you and there was
no different kind of experience I
resolved with Melissa Etheridge and she
said her mom was a big fan this is my
tragedy now people told me that their
mothers are fans do you you keep track
of what's going on in England because
the British government has proposed
outlawing incitement to religious hatred
act a law and according to one opponent
since the day the Satanic Verses was
published in 1989 a religious hardcore
has sought a law to grant religious
beliefs and practices immunity from
criticism unfavorable analysis or
ridicule and earlier this year the Sikh
playwright GUP read bottie was forced
into hiding after receiving death
threats for her play Betty because it
depicted sexual abuse in a Sikh temple
something we know has never happened
never happens no I've been actually very
involved in that in the in the in the
campaign to stop that extraordinarily
stupid bill from becoming law because it
seems quite proper to protect people
from racial discrimination and racial
abuse but you cannot ring-fence people's
ideas I mean that's you know the thing
that destroys freedom of speech which is
the thing without which there aren't any
other freedoms and are you doing that
because of your own experience or
because you are the
to Panamera well both you know but I but
I mean I feel I have some personal
reason to speak on the matter and and
but it is it is I'm happy to say that I
mean it's part of Blair's ridiculous
arrogance that he thinks he can do this
and then just say trust me it'll be fine
you know we don't mean me where have you
heard that recently you know well
Britain doesn't have its Bill of Rights
either they know there is no there's
nothing they guarantees free but he's
been saying all along no no it's not
about censorship it's about preventing
hate speech and so on but it doesn't say
anywhere in the bill that it's not about
censorship but it may and it and the
safeguards are incredibly weak and
basically depend on a particular
government minister making a decision
about whether something can be
prosecuted or not and I think god
preserve us the day that free speech
becomes them at the mercy of a
government minister you know subject to
political pressures and so on you know
so there's a strange thing going on in
England at the House of Lords this
unelected body is the one which is now
defending the freedoms of the country
while the House of Commons cravenly
following the Blair government is is
trying to destroy these freedoms and the
House of Lords has now kicked out this
bill a number of times and it does seem
as if this last defeat in the Lord's was
so heavy that the government seems to
have understood that it's got to
compromise if we had it in this country
who would you want to be the government
minister Judith Miller or hi Louis Livie
you know that's such an embarrassment of
riches questions from the audience and
if you have a question wait until
someone comes around with the microphone
there's a I hope that the person who
asks is in too much in the middle
because of people with microphones will
have a really hard time do I see any
hands you see your hand yes okay come
over here when I was reading Psalm ear
the clown getting a bit too close
I found this highly sympathetic did you
was he intended to be a villain did you
at all view him as a villain I mean he
does go around killing people
you want repeat the question the
question is did I view him as a villain
Shalimar the clown because he does go
around killing people yeah I mean I
think you see I thought if I could
present have presented him as a
straightforward villain and that would
have been very easy I could say here's a
bad guy don't like him you know and I
think it would have been pretty boring
free to write and possibly quite boring
to read I thought it would be more
interesting if you initially fell in
love with him you know if you discovered
he that he was somebody that you
actually cared about you know rather
than being a cartoon villain because you
know a cartoon has no moral choice a
cartoon can only be what he can be you
know the roadrunner has to run and the
coyote has to chase and they can't swap
roles but a human being has retains the
power of moral choice and if you can
create a human being that you care about
the reader cares about and then show him
making shocking moral choices no I think
actually in some way the force of those
choices is increased you know the impact
of those choices is he is increased on
the reader because it's somebody you
mind about you know and you did the same
thing with Max Ophuls
because he's less than admirable in the
way he does many things in his life and
yet you wanted us to care you care about
I think it's more interesting to care
about people and then worry about the
choices they make you know I mean I
think all of the characters in this book
are a bit like that I mean bunny for
example you know running off for the
American ambassador breaking your
husband's heart probably a bad idea you
know on the whole ladies avoid but you
know then you then I but when I was
writing really this the scene where she
has to choose you know where she
discovers that he desires her and she
has a very brief moment to make up her
mind yeah I thought well just imagine
yourself as this 18 year old girl who
believes herself to be gifted as dancer
and who has ambitions you know to
broaden her horizons and so on and and
understands that the life she has it
means that she will almost never be able
to to realize those dreams it's an input
they're impossible dreams and then
suddenly by this kind of
random chance that she's asked to
perform in front of this very powerful
man
and he looks at her with desire she
understands that she's got about 10
seconds to make a life-changing decision
which is either she says yes or suggests
yes in which case it's quite possible
that the universe will simply expand
gigantically many things which were
fantasies will become possibilities etc
and the downside is she's going to break
the heart of the man who loves her and
the other side is the other possibility
is that she would say no whereupon she
would not break his heart but that door
with that little door the universe would
slam shut and it would never open again
as long as she lived and she's 18 years
old the question is how do you make that
choice you know I think it's the point
about the book is that moral choices are
not black-and-white choices you know I
mean that it's there's no absolutely
good choice and no absolutely bad choice
you have to weigh these things you know
and when people weigh them and choose
the wrong thing if we if we if we care
about the characters than we are pained
by their choice you know and that's
that's the art of the novel another
question probably back row in the middle
in a red t-shirt wait for the microphone
wait for the mic you said before that
perhaps that perhaps it was max who
didn't want his name changed as opposed
to you and I was wondering if you
consider your characters to be their own
entities and to make their own decisions
regardless of what you may be we have to
pass it up is there somebody who could
hurt it who can then tell us you're
gonna have to speak with speaking the
very loud kitty the shout shout
regardless of what you want yeah I did
not see the question that the question
is do I consider the the characters to
be independent entities who make their
own decisions regardless of what I want
and the answer is somewhat yes because I
think when you're making a fictional
character of course you have enormous
freedom you can make the character
anything you feel like you know but once
you have made the character you are then
bound by the rules of the character
you've made you know at that point
you're not free and don't you sometimes
even hear them speaking in your head
even when you're trying to do something
else I yeah you do dinner or something
well I know I once I once made a
terrible mistake I wrote a novel and I
found they were intruding in my view
that they do intrude and they annoy
they're pests sometimes there's a I for
instance what I wrote Midnight's
Children there's there's a as selim
Gretz
older in the novel he gets more and more
passive you know instead of being a
protagonist you know he becomes more or
less a victim things are done to him
and I didn't like that you know and I
kept trying to shift it I kept trying to
make him more you know proactive and
kind of take charge and though every
time I wrote those things they were
lousy you know and I said I eventually
understood I can't do this you know this
is who he is and and this is the way
he's grown up and I have to respect the
character that I've made you know and
tell his story and so you do sometimes
not have absolute freedom to make the
character do what you like you know and
in this book there were a couple of
moments when the characters made me go
in directions that I hadn't expected I
mean which were helpful you know in for
instance near the end of the book I was
worried about the last part of the book
when it actually does get you know the
darkness starts piling up
that it might get too dark and the
comedy stops and the tragedy gets going
you know and I didn't want it to be
unrelieved darkness and there's a moment
there where where India goes to Kashmir
late in the novel and she finds out you
know she stands beside her mother's
grave and etc and and really that's the
moment of closing the circle but the
thing that I hadn't expected I knew she
was going to do that what I hadn't
expected is that she was going to fall
in love or rather that somebody was
going to fall in love with her and that
she was going to in her very defended
and guarded way begin to allow the
possibility of love into her life you
know and when it happened I thought oh
this is good you know I I thought thank
goodness for this because it means that
there's you know now one note of the
music which is soaring upwards
you know while everything else is
getting you know deep and darker and it
needs it you know that the novel needs
it and that was entirely just a
discovery on the page you know I mean I
hadn't I hadn't been planning to do it
and in a way the two characters found
their way to each other you know and and
then of course I had to go back and
rewrite earlier stuff you know because
the young guy who she who she becomes
involved with was going to be a very
trivial character you know just an
enabler
somebody could drive the Jeep you know
but I then had to go back and give him a
backstory and so that when you said when
he falls in love with her you know who
he is
but that was a moment where really the
characters on that day on the page made
it happen and enormous ly improved that
bit of the book we are pretty much
running out of time we have time for one
or two more over there she's been yeah
there's one right over there is there no
microphone long blonde hair yeah I've
got a question
you've permitted some of your work to be
translated to the state I'm thinking of
Haroon and I understand that you
actually cooperated a lot with the
company in Berkeley to do that would you
imagine
do you imagine perhaps something similar
happening with Shalimar the question is
would he allow this to be true
to the stage as Midnight's Children has
as Haroon and Arun and Midnight Sun and
Bert were both done well I was very that
the original production of horrendous
year stories was done at the National
Theatre in London and actually I wasn't
very involved in that it they they just
did it but I remember going to see it
and be absolutely entranced by how
beautifully they done it you know and
and with just the extraordinary pleasure
of being able to sit in a room with an
audience watching the thing that you
imagined come to life you know so it was
it was huge fun and and in that case
really zero effort because I didn't do a
thing except except write the original
book no and I said to them you know if
everybody likes to play I'm taking the
credit and if they don't like it it's
your fault and then they did Midnight's
Children and I was more involved I
helped with the adaptation and so on and
again I mean I had great fun with it
although I think it's true to say about
the play of Midnight's Children that the
people who enjoyed it most were people
who had not read the novel you know
because I think the problem of a
600-page normal is that there's a
process of compression that happens you
know Haroon is quite a small book so you
can do it on the stage but Midnight's
Children is you know singers fans even
and this one would be almost impossible
I don't think you do it on the stage but
I think people tell me it's the one of
my books that might actually get made
into a movie because it appears to be
cinematic I mean it's in LA and also
it's got something which none of my
other books have had which is a major
central character who is to put it
bluntly white you know I mean they're
all my other books have had only Indian
characters and it's been very difficult
to cast them out of Hollywood but now
suddenly there's this socking great part
for a Hollywood star which again makes
it makeable and aging huh well no you
have to cast it young because most of
the most of the story he's a man in his
prime
they older [ __ ] just at the very big
one in one scene so I don't know we have
to think I can't think who I would cast
actually I I thought it if Gregory Peck
were available but but he's not working
so much what about your own film career
many people probably only recognize you
as the guy who pointed everyone to the
bathroom in Bridget Jones diary well
well I'm glad you brought that up okay
now I thought you might appreciate now
you're talking about this seriously okay
one more question and you would you want
to choose one okay somebody over here
yes with a microphone I wanted to know
do you consider your characters to be
archetypes of the locations that they
represent for instance Shalimar do you
think his instability is is like typical
of that sort of region where there's a
lot of conflict what do you think about
the West Bank or or the area that the
Kurds are fighting with the Iraqis over
do you do you think that that sort of
instability and violence is going to be
Illustrated and further example I think
the question though part of the question
is do I think of the characters as being
archetypal of the situations that they
come from and I think the simple answer
is no I don't and that's say one of the
things I really resisted in this book oh
you would you know somebody was quoting
I think Joe was quoting the bit from
midnight zone about the the lust for
allegory and I think in in this book I
really wanted to resist that you know I
didn't want to say that this character
represents the jihadist mentality you
know oh that that character represents
another kind of mentality because I
think when characters become excessively
representative in that way it is very it
is virtually impossible to make them
live as individuals yeah and I think
it's like it's better to say here is one
case this is the story of one person in
this appalling historical situation and
his choices were these for these reasons
not to say all people would make choices
like this or for these reasons but but I
think if you could tell the truth about
one person in a given situation the
reader can imagine how other people
might react in that situation and you I
think that's a very important space that
a book needs to leave space for the
reader you know because I think the
imagination of the reader is very
important you know in the act of in in
in the business of a novel I think the
imagination of the reader is what
completes the book you know that's why a
book is different for everyone who reads
it because people bring to it whatever
they bring to it you know and I find
already in the short time that this book
has been out enormous difference of
response you know I mean given that
these four characters are there there
are people who will come up and say and
focus on very different ones you know
there are some people for whom the
character of India is the character that
there can't get out of their minds and
for other people it's Max and for other
people it's Sharma the clown and it's
because of this because of them you know
and I'd like that
I like it that you can't prescribe the
reading of the book you know that and I
think one of the one of the things that
was awful about what happened to the
Satanic Verses
is that I was endlessly being asked to
say what the book meant you know what
were you trying to do what was this
about what was that about why did you
say this why did you write that and my
instinct is novelist is not to answer
those questions is to say well you read
it you tell me you know because that's
exactly the space for the reader that
you want to leave you don't want to
prescribe the reading you know in that
book I had to I've over the last
whatever it is now 17 years I've had to
so much kind of over determine the
reading of the book and if so that
people can see what I was at you know
but it's been harmful I think I've
talked to playwrights about what happens
when an actor reads their lines and in a
way that they didn't imagine when they
were writing those lines well for a
novelist every reader is an actor
reading the lines in a very personal way
and very dinner
oh there's a wonderful it might be a
good way to end my great friend Harold
Pinter who just won the Nobel Prize and
hooray for him but Harold is very bad is
very notorious for not explaining his
stuff right and and there's a there's a
I read that you know somebody once asked
about one of his plays what was it about
it he said it's a play about a man
sitting in a room and two other people
come in you know that's the birthday
party and but this story is I believe to
be true stories I was told it by a
director called David Laveau who
directed a revival of Pinchas play no
man's land in which Harold played one of
the roles and very good English actor
called Paul Eddington played the other
which would originally be in Ralph
Richardson and John Gielgud in the first
production and anyway there's a in
rehearsal there was this moment where
Paul Eddington says to Harold he says
you know Harold I don't quite I don't
completely get this this speech and
could he just just help me out and work
where's how is it supposed to go you
know it's a picture takes the play
script it looks of it and hands it back
to him and says the author's intentions
are not clear from the text thank you so
much Salman Rushdie thank you all for
coming thank you to Joe PMO and Queens
College